[Applaudissements]
le dit l'adage celui qui refuse de
manger ne peut pas vouloir aller faire
caca après donc excusez moi mais oui
donc en fait pour savoir de quoi vous
parlez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout cela il mise à part et entre eux
est ce que vous l'avez vu vous avez vu
ou pas ils seront faits maison des
missions l'une on voit là on est un peu
l'émission c'est bien ce qui se passe
parce que je travaillais études et je
suis dans le cinéma
oui ça m'a étonné quand même les films
alors elle est connue à non pas du tout
mais c'est passé c'est non on arrête ton
parce que moi j'ai dit que vous n'étiez
pas idiot si aucune diffusion là on
arrête tout mais qui s'arrête je vais
pas signer de papier parce que ça on
avait prévu avec tf alors il à l agonie
dois dire qu'elle n'est pas connue aux
états unis jérôme jérôme tu arrêtes on
arrête ou là on adore